Sáng nay, một hai tăng chiến, phái chung không khi với cuộc giống bình giữa hành tại trụ đồ hành hội,
tại đùng viện cám lành tỉ khánh hoa, cuộc giống bình trên biển với sự tham gia của hai con nhân rất Việt Nam,
cạnh rất biển Việt Nam, một đội viên phòng, hại đội rất quan thương trực, cũng giơ phương biển khi tại hiện đại.
Chân cuộc giống bình trên biển, các biển đội tâu đi thành hai hàng rau, chính giữa trên cùng là tâu chỉ vì cuộc một năm trên hình đạo.
Thức đó tâu chỉ đi về tối hình giữa bình trên biển theo thứ tự, dịch biển đội mai vai thì vị cơ để hát xe sấu,
chức thăng sân ngâm cả hai tắm và biển đội tâu cứ hộ đà năng, tâu bộ trở của hai con nhân rất Việt Nam.
Dịch biển đội tâu hai tội rất quan thương trực, biển đội tâu tôn trà SPA, bốn hai không bài, bốn đội viên phòng, biển đội tâu tôn trà đà năng lớp để nâng hàng dình của tưởng nư và cạnh sát biển Việt Nam.
Bình đội tâu vào tê tê bốn trăm tê, tâu tên được một hai bốn một tắm, một hai bốn một rửa, tâu ngâm kí lâu sấu bà sấu, tâu hộ về chống gần lớp 1 năm chính và tâu hộ về tên được sê váp bà trở chính của hai con nhân dân Việt Nam.
Ngay sau khi tâu chỉ vì việc đối hình giữa bình, các biển đội tâu chỉ khi kắc đội hình trên biển, giữa hình trực A, chữ V và khoả trắng.
Giữa biển các lực lượng bốn trang trên biển, đã tạo nên một bước trang hùng trang, thì hệ hệ hệ hệ tổn hợp của thế trận cút phòng tần dân và an ninh nhân dân trên biển.
Đông thời gửi đi thông việc mạnh mẽ về một việc Nam yếu chủng hoa biển, nhưng kinh quét, kinh chỉ bảo vệ chủ quyền biển đạo thương liên của tộc quốc.
Đông thời cũng kinh dự, tự hào, là đội lực để các thế hệ cán bộ chính sĩ, các lực lượng bốn trang trên biển, kết bước trang, mào vệ bốn trang chủ quyền biển đạo thương liên của tộc quốc.
Có khăn bữa đất nước phát triển hùng cơm, tự vợ bước trang hệ đại mới.